so let's say you're dead set on buying
the new m1 ipad pro
because of its killer m1 performance the
newly added thunderbolt port
the crazy midi led display or for
basically any other reason
but you have one major problem you have
no idea which model or which upgrades
you should be buying
well that's exactly what i'm gonna help
you figure out
in this video because you can actually
make a couple of very important mistakes
if you're not aware of all of them in
fact there are seven mistakes that you
need to avoid
when buying your new m1 ipad pro so
before i get into the buyer's guide
portion of this video
let's get into the first mistake you
need to avoid
and that's buying the 11 ipad pro model
thinking that you're getting the new xdr
display
that crazy display with over 10 000 midi
leds
over 2500 local dimming zones and up to
1600 nits of peak brightness is only
available
on the 12.9 inch ipad pro model so don't
make that mistake
yes it's definitely more expensive
starting at 1100
but this display is mind blowingly good
packing even better hdr capabilities
than apple's
six thousand dollar pro display xdr
since that display only has around five
to six hundred local dimming zones
which can lead to some ghosting issues
but the ipad pro won't have that issue
so if you're someone who loves to watch
movies or videos on your ipad
especially at night the new mini led
display is going to be killer
since the black bars you get while
watching movies will be pitch black
and not gray like they've always been in
the past now moving on to mistake number
two
don't think that you absolutely need the
mini led display
because if you're not viewing hdr
content it's gonna be limited to the
same exact 600 nits
as the 11 inch ipad pro's lcd display
which by the way
is still a really nice display on top of
that the 12.9 inch ipad pro is
much larger than the smaller model on
paper the difference between
11 and 12.9 inches doesn't sound like
that big of a deal
but the larger ipad actually has a 3x2
aspect ratio
which makes it very tall so for someone
who really prioritizes portability
it actually might just make sense to
save 300.
and get the 11 inch ipad pro if you
don't really care about hdr content now
as for mistake number three
i know a lot of people are getting
really hyped about the fact that the
ipad pro can now get up to 16 gigs of
ram
but you might actually be making a huge
mistake by going for it first of all you
gotta deck out your ipad pro with at
least
one terabyte of storage to get 16 gigs
of ram
which means you're spending at least
fifteen hundred dollars
for the 11 inch or 1800 for the 12.9
inch model
that is a lot of money to pay if you're
trying to get the extra ram
especially since almost every app that's
available on the app store right now
is optimized to run at a peak of six
gigs of ram which is what the previous
ipad pro model had
and it ran basically every app just fine
so 8 gigabytes on the new ipad pro is
already a nice step
up but 16 gigs is absolutely overkill
for almost every app available right now
so the reality is that most people
do not need 16 gigabytes of ram unless
they're planning to run
high performance apps in the future like
potentially final cut pro
logic pro and xcode which are rumored to
be announced at apple's wwdc event but
if you were already planning on getting
one terabyte of storage
anyway then the extra ram is definitely
an awesome addition
and i'd say that it's gonna help this
ipad pro hold its value
well into the future when we start
getting more high-end apps for the ipad
and that actually leads us to mistake
number four be very mindful about the
amount of storage you buy
because the base model comes with 128
gigs of storage
and i would argue that it's not enough
if you're planning to be downloading a
bunch of games
apps or doing professional productivity
work so definitely get at least 256 gigs
of storage
unless you're mainly just going to be
browsing the web or watching youtube
videos
and if you're planning on having this
ipad pro completely replace your laptop
i would get at least 512 gigs especially
if you're doing professional work on it
now for mistake number five
remember that the ipad pro now has a
thunderbolt port
so if you're going to be investing into
some nice accessories
don't make the mistake of buying the
slower ones that don't take advantage of
thunderbolt for example this sabrint
rocket portable ssd that we recently
reviewed
supports thunderbolt 3 so you can now
get crazy fast 2.7 gigabytes per second
transfer speeds
on the ipad pro whereas many of the usbc
drives
are limited to around 500 to 1000
megabytes per second
on top of that the new thunderbolt port
means you can use thunderbolt docks
like this one from owc which turns one
port
into three full speed thunderbolt ports
which can be used for drives
displays and whatever else and they even
have a higher end model with a bunch of
other ports
which are very convenient but keep in
mind that these ones require dc
power since they're so powerful but if
you're just trying to get a simple usbc
hub for the ipad pro
you can also go with something like this
which is our recommended hub
since it's a reputable brand and it has
a variety of ports
and is currently on sale for 76 dollars
if you click the coupon icon so if you
guys are interested in any of those
accessories
we're gonna leave some links down in the
description below now getting into
mistake number six
don't buy the 5g model unless you know
that you absolutely need it
the main reason for that is that this
year it's now a 200
upgrade compared to 150 for the previous
model
so you're definitely paying a lot of
extra money just for that 5g option
and in reality there are now more
locations with free wi-fi than ever
before
and since the ipad pro supports wi-fi 6
you're good to go for the future
with fast speeds and since every new
iphone now comes with 5g support
you can just use tethering off of your
iphone if you're ever in a situation
where you don't have free wi-fi but then
again having super fast 5g
directly on your ipad pro might be worth
it
if you rely on fast download or upload
speeds
but just keep in mind the higher 200
price for 5g
and for mistake number seven if you're
thinking of upgrading to the new 12.9
inch ipad pro
and you already have a 12.9 inch magic
keyboard case
there's a chance that your keyboard
won't be compatible
with this new ipad pro because it's
actually a bit thicker
so the case might not work properly
within now this hasn't been confirmed
just yet but it's definitely something
to keep in mind because
if you need to buy a new 350 dollar
magic keyboard case
that changes the upgrade options that
you can afford on the ipad pro itself
so now with all of those mistakes out of
the way let's get into
the buyer's guide first off if you're
someone who's simply looking for a
reliable
and fast tablet with a really nice
display to watch
shows and youtube videos play games and
occasionally do some productivity work
then i'd say that the 11 inch ipad pro
is a great choice
starting at just 800 but i would
definitely recommend getting at least
256
gigs of storage and i don't think that
you should get 16 gigs of ram
and if you're thinking of getting it
mainly for the touchscreen or apple
pencil use
like for note-taking or drawing then i'd
argue that you don't really need
the crazy mini led display on the 12.9
inch model
and you especially don't need 16 gigs of
ram now if you're thinking of taking it
to
the next level and getting the magic
keyboard case to turn it into a
dedicated laptop replacement the 11 inch
is still a great choice
because you're gonna be saving a lot of
money compared to the 12.9 inch
and it's going to be way more portable
as well
you'll probably also want at least 512
gigs of storage
if you're taking file management and
productivity work seriously
this is going to be great for students
because you'll be able to use it like a
laptop
with that magic keyboard case that
actually has a charging port
built into the hinge freeing up the main
thunderbolt port for transferring your
files and whatever else
now if you're going to be going all out
and using the ipad pro for professional
level
video editing programming music
production or photo editing
with those pro mac apps that we're
expecting to come
at wwdc then i'd shoot for that one
terabyte of storage model
that comes with 16 gigs of ram which
will really free up the system
and make it as future proof as possible
and as far as the 12.9 inch ipad pro
with the mini led display
this is gonna be the one to buy for
those who really care about the display
quality
more than anything else especially for
people who like to watch movies
with their ipad and i can definitely see
a lot of professionals
buying this 12.9 inch model just for
that insane hdr quality
with 1600 nits of peak brightness so
it's going to be perfect for hdr video
editing
even better than the 6 000 pro display
xdr which is super impressive
so there you guys go hopefully this
video helps you make a decision
and if it did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe
and definitely feel free to use the
links down below to those accessories
and the ipad pro
but if you're still confused on which
one to buy comment your specific use
case
down in the comment section below and
we'll help you make a decision
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
you